Tony Dungy NBC football night in America
analyst Tony how's the offseason hey it
all season's been great Dan I get a lot
of things done having fun and looking
forward to next year already but it was
a fun offseason just just relaxing the
Eagles just signed LeGarrette Blount to
a one-year deal what's your reaction I'm
surprised I just I don't understand
players sometimes I don't know that you
could have a better situation than he
had in New England and I don't know if
it's about money or what but it seems
like you're said you know what I can win
I can be utilized I can score a lot of
touchdowns III don't understand but you
know hopefully it works out form
Philadelphia you know needs a power back
so maybe it'll be good but if I I don't
know why you would not want to play for
the Patriots in this situation well
maybe it's to get paid because he's
already got his Super Bowl rings so that
might have something to do with it
you know everybody does and you can't
knock people from wanting to get paid
that that's part of it but gosh I always
felt like you win enough Super Bowls and
you you're going to reap a lot of
benefits and maybe running back though
it's a different situation you have only
got so many carries so many years I got
to ring the bell and get that big payday
one time but I know we we've we had guys
who did that I remember Dominick rose
after our Super Bowl went to Oakland and
he got paid well but he came back to us
is that if you were sick he hadn't have
taken that hiatus can you see any of
these rookie quarterbacks playing
significant time this year you know I
really could I'm curious with the Shawn
Watson I'm hearing everything they're
saying hey we're not going to plan early
and but you see what what happened last
year with Carson Wentz and you know how
well he played I just think especially
now when you invest that much and you
get these guys you have to get them on
the field to me sooner than later also
I know you've had some comments New York
Newsday had some quotes with Colin
Kaepernick the biggest reason why Colin
Kaepernick is not on a team right now is
what I think the perception of his
talent yes it all stems back to not
nailing for the national anthem and the
reaction that that's going to get from
fans but if people perceive Colin
Kaepernick as a difference maker as a
guy who could be their starting
quarterback and help them win gain he
would be signed now and people would
deal with the repercussions I think
everybody sees him maybe as a backup is
he a guy you know really help us am I
just going to get three or four games a
year if that's the case it's not worth
the headache it's not worth the
distraction it's not worth the number of
fans we would turn off I think that that
goes without saying
would you take Colin Kaepernick I don't
have a problem with what Colin
Kaepernick did and expressing his
feeling I think he's getting better at
you know really letting people know why
he's doing things you know again I would
be evaluating what can he bring to the
table is he going to help us win and I
still think if you designed the system
for him and utilized him right that that
weaponry you know it makes sense in
Seattle I'm hearing that they might be
interested he could run the same offense
he'd give you some of the same things
that Russell Wilson gives if Malcolm
gets hurt like he did last year and
wasn't as effective in there for
stretches you've got a guy who could
complain some games for you in that
system so yes I think in certain
situation I hear sitting there and
you're just a drop back passing and
you're not going to change the system
form you probably won't get what you
need yeah that's the key talking to Tony
Dungy football night in America analyst
is is he going as a starter or as a
backup and what's the system like when
you get there Seattle he can go in he
understands the system he played against
them twice a year when he was in San
Francisco what I don't understand Tony
is the Jets and Browns not interested in
Colin Kaepernick why
well they're looking for long-term
solutions and they've got you know
they've got certain style that they're
going to play you know that that's I
think what has everybody baffled in the
football world is we see these
situations where people don't have
quarterbacks there they're not winning
they don't have a guy they can hang
their head on and we say wouldn't you at
least look at this guy with Vince's
Super Bowls and cause problems and put
up you know four hundred yards total
offense games wouldn't you at least book
and and that's what is baffling to
people because there aren't enough
quality quarterbacks to go around yeah I
look at the brown suit you well let me
start with the judge I think they if I
have three or four quarterbacks that
means I don't have one quarterback right
that's the OL thing and I believe you're
right and then with the Browns you know
I understand what Hugh Jack's is doing
that they missed out on Carson Wentz
maybe they found gold in DeSean Kaiser
but they're they're not close they could
be in this situation again next year
Tony and then they can be on the clock
and the quarterback staring them right
in the face to me that that's the thing
that kind of hits you with Cleveland
situation you passed on some
quarterbacks you said hey we evaluate
all these guys we don't really like them
enough and and some of these guys have
done well but the problem is the guys
that you pick you still don't have one
so if you pass on Carson Wentz and you
had good quarterback play that would be
one thing but when you when you pass on
those guys and it doesn't seem like you
fill the bill then that's when people
get a little bit gunshot so I think they
do they've got a they've got to find a
guy and they've got to say this is our
guy we're going to play him and develop
him and go and that's really what they
need to get that franchise going Tom
Brady's wife a couple hours ago and the
CBS Morning Show said that Tom had a
concussion he's had concussions every
year we don't know we've never heard
anything about this there was no report
no of injury report diagnosis with Tom
Brady do you think Payton ever lied to
you and and that he had a concussion and
never told you I think players I think
that happens
a lot of times I think guys do not want
to tell you and weave I say this I had
more guys tell me that they could go
they were ready to go there was nothing
wrong with them and the doctors are
saying no you have to hold them out you
know I hit I can tell you I've had three
playing football one in college in two
in the NFL one I told the dista doctors
and one I really didn't you get a little
lightheaded
you're all on the bench you recover and
you just go back in that's that's kind
of the nature of the beast I think we're
educating our players better now but I'm
sure they're guys who have them to tell
their wives that don't tell the team the
coaches or the doctor yeah this is this
is an interesting situation here because
it's not like an unnamed source this is
his wife saying he's had concussions
every year and he had a concussion last
season and didn't miss any time
what's the NFL what do you do with this
information if you're the NFL well I
don't think it's new I don't think
that's surprising I would say that
probably happens a lot and I don't think
you can blame the league all you can do
is educate if guys you know it's one
thing if she says hey does the doctors
new in the team who and and everybody
knew but they didn't put it out I think
what she's saying is he may have come
home and told me and not told anybody
else so I don't know I think you just
have to try to continue to monitor it to
continue to have the people in place to
look but would you we've been on the
sidelines we were there in Denver and we
saw Cam Newton get rocked and with
Howard they'd not stop in this game how
are they not taking him off off the
field yeah
so it's an inexact science right now I'm
monitoring it for sure yeah but these
guys don't want to come out Brady
they don't like Peyton wouldn't come out
of a game Tony even when he wasn't
injured or had a commune oh he just
refused to come out even if it was a
blowout yeah I mean it's just guys want
to play they want to be there that's the
mentality of football from
from way back and I know my last few
years we did try to educate the players
hey you've got to let us know you got a
self report you've got a report on your
teammates if you guys having a problem
in injury you know you've got to be the
good teammate and let us know we had all
kinds of people looking for but again
that players mentality is hey I've got a
plate and I'm always going to tell you
that I'm well enough play so some some
other ways you have to figure it out
tone good to talk to you good to see you
the other night and I'll be seeing you
soon always good brother looking forward
to it that's Tony Dungy football night
in America the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience